one of the nice things about the
infinite game is two players or more who
sell basically the same product for
basically the same price for basically
the same quality can all be wildly
successful at the same time like no one
wins
and and remember we're deciding the
metrics so we could decide that it's
market share or revenue or profit and
we're making these arbitrary comparisons
to arbitrary other players and we can be
all high and mighty about ourselves you
know general motors decided that um that
market share was the thing and they were
obsessed with being number one in market
share meanwhile they were losing money
hand over fist year after year after
year
not sure if that's a very uh infinite
minded focus uh because you're clearly
going to put yourself out of the game
remember when when circuit city went
bankrupt best buy didn't win anything
um if anything they had to change the
way that they played because amazon
became a much more dominant force in the
industry and so they couldn't actually
do the things that they used to do and
this is what it means to be an infinite
player means you understand that it's
not simply about repeating the same
thing that's always worked but it's
adapting with politics and culture and
technology and it's not actually about
competing against another player on in
the field but the only true competitor
in an infinite game is actually yourself
how do i make my product better this
year than it was last year how do i give
better advice this year than i gave last
year how to become a better leader this
year than i was than i was last year and
it's a constant constant education of
constant constant improvement
i can tell you a funny story which
you'll recognize from the book which
really captures the difference between a
finite and infinite mindset and it comes
from a personal experience
i had the opportunity to speak at an
education summit for microsoft and then
a few months later i was asked to speak
at an education summit for apple now
this was back in the steve ballmer
days when steve ballmer
ran microsoft
and at the microsoft summit the vast
majority of the executives spent the
vast majority of their presentations
talking about how to beat apple
balmer at the time was obsessed with
beating apple
um at the apple summit a hundred percent
of the executives spent a hundred
percent of their presentations talking
about how to help teachers teach and how
to help students learn
one was obsessed with their mission the
other one was obsessed with beating
their competition
guess which one was struggling with
issues of trust cooperation and
innovation
um
so at the end of my uh talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune when it was a thing this was
microsoft's response to the ipod
and again there's plenty of uh uh
evidence and footage of balmer talking
about he was going to beat the ipod and
this was going to be the best product
ever and i have to say this little piece
of technology was quite good it was very
user-friendly it was it worked very well
it was it was it was a really nice
little product um
at the end of my apple talk i was
sharing a taxi with a senior apple
executive uh and i couldn't help myself
i happened i just had to stir the pot
uh so i i turned to him and i said you
know
microsoft gave me their new zune
and it is so much better than your ipod
touch
and he turned to me and he said
i have no doubt
and the conversation was over
because an infinite player understands
sometimes you have the better product
sometimes they have the better product
sometimes you're ahead and sometimes
you're behind
the goal is not to beat your competitor
the goal is to outdo yourself
where microsoft was obsessed with
beating apple apple ignored microsoft
and was obsessed with outdoing itself uh
a year later apple introduced the iphone
which rendered both the ipod and the
zoom completely obsolete